it is a truly pleasure for me to
introduce
stephanie and angeli i we met
in the hamburg um artificial
intelligence meetup
and they told me they met in the master
at the university of hamburg the master
it is called
intelligence adaptive systems i post the
two links in the chat so
pretty cool stuff and yeah the room is
yours please please
thank you thanks i'll just share my
you're right
great so yeah first of all
um i hope you're all doing well we had
that first question that we actually
didn't really touch upon
in the um in the uh
getting to know each other which was um
house 2021 and i hope it's
it's okay and i hope that today you have
a good day
and um yeah thank you to the organizers
um for
organizing this event and for having us
here and thank you for everyone else for
your interest in our um talk and yeah
i hope that um you enjoy it
and so the title is from rgbd images to
complete
point clouds that's kind it's quite a
lot and let's see what is behind that
title
so first of all who are we i hope that
you see both of us here
in the grid on the side so i'm anjali
and steffi
is there she's waiting
so um yeah we're both from that course
that as maria
introduced which is called intelligent
adaptive systems
at university of hamburg and it's kind
of a fancy name for
another fancy um term which is
artificial intelligence and
also robotics but mainly the software
side of robotics
and i also co-founded a company last
year with two
other of my friends and um it's called
adelab
and you can find us online um under
adderlab.ai and we do consulting for ml
and ai and we're starting out but yeah
we're having fun
so check us out if you're interested and
you can find me
on twitter there's my handle you can
find me on linkedin if you want to get
in touch
i'm kind of active there yeah and then
stephanie please
say something about yourself yeah i'm
studying
the same course i'm just about to start
my
master thesis and hopefully we'll talk
about that at some point
soon as well and you can also find me on
twitter at kubrick underscore
and um also i wrote some medium articles
um i will tell you a little bit about
that later and
get a link on there as well and you can
find me on github as well where i'm
fairly active
thank you okay
let's get to it so hands
this is what it's about tonight it's
about grasping so we're going to
kind of set the tone with a little task
that we prepared
because most of the time as we as humans
are grasping things we're not really
considering it
consciously and this is why i want to
kind of
prime you and i would like to ask you to
look around where you're sitting
and look whether or not there are any
objects close to you
um and um they should be of a size that
is graspable with one or
it could be two hands but something that
you can easily grasp
exactly and then as maria is already
trying to do she's
i would like to ask you to actually
grasp it just
take the object nice
and then put it back or put it in front
of you
and then i want to ask you to do it once
again but this time
think about it take your time consider
all the sub
tasks basically that go into grasping
the object and think about the
information
that you're processing um what are you
noticing about the object what is
going through your mind as you're
shaping your hands
and anticipating the grasp and planning
it
nice nicely done mariah
okay nice
so as you might notice um there's
actually a lot of information that goes
into
into grasping right so you're as you're
focusing on your object you're
considering its shape you already
already know kind of what dimensions is
it really tiny is it
is a large object you also have some
knowledge about how the object is shaped
in areas that you don't even see
from where you're sitting because it's
actually in the back right
but you're considering all of these
different informations weight surface
structure and so on and so forth
you get the idea and so let's look at
how it looks like
when a robot grasps on something we have
a little video that we actually just
borrowed from youtube
and just have a look
at the actuators the hands of the robot
it has these like two hooks with joints
and then its head you can see in the
middle down there
it has two cameras and it's
moving quite slowly because it's
processing all the information right
and so
yeah so we have some two stills from
that video
so if you notice the first picture up
there um the robot is interacting with a
very cluttered environment right so this
refrigerator thank you
chef for pointing um the refrigerator
has all these different objects and
um the owner probably asked the robot to
to find the
gatorade bottle and the robot is
approaching it using its rgb camera that
it's equipped with
to segment out the um the shape and then
it also has some knowledge about how far
away it is right so it has some depth
information there too
it's probably equipped with some kind of
depth sensor could be an infrared sensor
and um it has a kind of
some understanding of the of some of the
three dimensional information
in that area there but what it doesn't
know is how the object looks
like from the back right it doesn't have
a 360 degree
representation of that object however
that could be very useful information
for shaping the hand and anticipating
the grasp
and so this is kind of what we
motivated our project
so yeah as i described to you the hands
of that robot
specifically were kind of simple let's
say
i had two fingers with a joint each so
not many degrees of freedom
so i call it so this is another example
how a robotic hand could look like
it has three fingers many joints
it has these um little black tips of the
fingers
these domes it's actually some kind of
rubber texture
and behind that is a tactile sensor and
so
stephanie and i we worked on another
project i think a year before
the one that we're talking about today
and there we
um classified whether or not the object
in the hand of that robot is slipping so
we have this little bottle there
just like some hair conditioner we cut
it open and then in one setting we
had it empty and then the other one we
used those
screw nuts that's the english word um
to have weight in it and then you get a
timeline time series of
um whether or not there's yeah um this
friction going through so this is just
to show you another example of another
problem that goes into robotic
manipulation and grasping
okay and now um
to today's lesson so what are we going
to actually teach you or
convey to you um i actually like the
term
impulse that a friend who's also here
likes to use so um the first impulse was
problems that go into robotic grasping
so we're actually unfortunately not
going to talk
much more about robots themselves um
but um we kind of try to explain how
the robotic problem set motivates our
project which
in itself is actually more the software
side of things
so we're using deep neural networks to
um
deal with that information that i talked
about earlier
the one that the information that is um
collected through the robotic head and
the eyes and the depth sensors
to create these three-dimensional
complete representations of that
for example gatorade bubble
and also we're going to touch upon the
topic of working with scientific
scientific
code repositories as open source is kind
of a
big thing and something that we want to
support and um
bring forward um uh yeah we we're just
briefly going to talk about a bit about
the
experience that we had with specifically
scientific
code repositories
so this what we did
this is a overview i know it's kind of a
lot of information on there
trying to lead you through it um so
what we're what we did in the project
was we tried to create a full pipeline
uh which we built up on upon two
networks in order to um take
this rgb image of a cluttered
environment
which here is um this data that we use
is from the ycb video data set
which has just a lot of these photos
with different household objects and
cluttered scenes and um
yeah we took these rgb images and then
used the segmentation network
to extract a certain target object that
we specified
um earlier um and and then we took the
depth map corresponding to it
to get a preliminary representation
that is incomplete and also very noisy
as you can see here
you can barely understand that this
could be a scissor
or a pair of scissors and then we took
another network
to create a completed three-dimensional
representation that if you would
rotate that it would have the complete
surface shape from all
perspectives
and yeah so the first task was the task
of semantic segmentation
and it's not really a hot
very recent topic anymore um
i would guess um it's something that has
been around for a couple of years and
a lot of very recent solutions um i mean
correct me if i'm wrong there might be
even nicer solutions now but just i'm
trying to say that
maybe some of you have already some idea
about that topic
still um semantics limitation what is
this
for anyone else um it's the problem of
classifying each and every pixel in an
image that wasn't seen before
so your network would see this get this
image
with the um these bikers
and the task would be to say which of
the pixels
belong to the person to the bicycle
or the background and what you want is
very accurate classification
right so you want to you want it to be
really good at
seeing what is in the image but you want
the network also
to be very good at um seeing where
the how the shape is i'm reconstructing
the shape so this mask actually
we look at it and we kind of can see
that there's a bicycle in there
because it's very precise spatially
and so this is what you would want with
that
type of uh network and um
yeah this is what we used as a sec
segnet
is its name and it's one
network that works really well and we
actually chose it
because it's kind of lightweight it
doesn't have
a lot of parameters as comparable
solutions
and as you can see it consists of an
encoder decoder
architecture so this is also a pattern
that if you work with ai
you you would have seen maybe before but
for
anyone else who hasn't the idea is that
you have an encoder
here in the beginning which is something
that you um
use is a convolutional neural network
that
you could also use for classifying an
image
and what it does it has these
convolutional layers
which are which are the blue ones and um
yeah it basically um goes through the
image
and searches for features that are
descriptive of what is in the image
and as you go down towards that
bottleneck the narrow
area there the features get more
abstract and more
descriptive of the overall concept kind
of
of what you're seeing there and so in
the end here in the
i mean here in the bottleneck what you
have is the information of
what you're seeing but if you're working
with segmentation
as i told earlier earlier you don't only
want to know what you're seeing
but also precisely where and how it's
shaped
and so this is why you take that
information and then you upscale it
again
so this is what the decoder does as as
the
layers here become larger the
information is kind of
spread back to the original positions
and it's um and this is happening with
the
technique that is called max pooling up
sampling
if you want to know more about that i
have an extra slide that we could talk
about in the q a
um however yeah so this is kind of
happening it's
projected back to its original position
and then in the end you have a
classification
output this is a softmax layer and for
each pixel it outputs
the probability of the pixel belonging
to the different classes
and then it takes the most probable
class and that's
that's your output there and this then
you get that map
yeah so ah that was a big quick
um so how do we now get from this
what we call a segmentation mask
to the representation that we showed you
earlier
so the incomplete point clouds and then
the complete point cloud
at the end so first of all short not on
point clouds
um some of you might have never worked
with us before and it was also new to us
before we started this project
so point clouds basically consist of
points and each point
um usually has a vector of x y and z
chord
right so it's in 3d space and they can
also have
additional information such as color but
in our case
we didn't deal with color we just took
this these x y and z
coordinates and you can actually see a
nice example a gif
here of a point cloud rotating
and what is important about them as a
representation
is that they have some special
properties so first of all
um they are unordered sets uh if you
imagine
an image a 2d image right and you would
take all the pixels and just shuffle
them
the image would look completely
different it wouldn't if you put it
through a classifier
it wouldn't get you the same result but
with point clouds
you need to be able to shuffle all the
points and still be able to get the same
classification result
so no matter in which order i put these
doughnut points into my classifier i
still wanted to
predict the donut um and then there's
interaction among points
meaning that the points that are close
to each other and
share some yeah some properties so for
instance if you imagine you had a point
cloud
depicting a plane then two points that
would be on the wing of the plane
close to each other would share more it
would have more in common
than one point on the wing and one point
on the wheel of the plane for instance
and then the third is the transformation
invariant so
you can also see this nicely here on the
gif because
since this thing is rotating right
sometimes it looks kind of odd but we
still want
our networks to be able to predict it's
a doughnut even when we just see it from
the side so no matter how we
rotate the point cloud as a whole or how
we translate it in space
it should still be lead to the same
prediction
okay and now um i'll actually want to
show you
a small video that we did of one of the
frames from our data set
and how this frame as a whole including
color information looks like
in the form of a point cloud so um as
you can see here
i'll just go forward a little bit so
this is um
roughly where the camera would have been
when it was taking this picture
and you can see that um here's the table
top here is the
here these objects that we're looking at
that we're interested in and here
there's a bit of
information missing and the same as if i
go back
here actually so right in front of the
scissors so the object that we
might care about there's some
information missing because
this part is occluded by this other box
and right in front of it
and if i play this video a bit more we
can actually see it from the side and
then we get a feeling
for how much information is actually
missing
so if you imagine you're a robot
you are missing basically i don't know
three quarters of this bottle or
of this box if you want if you're trying
to grab it um
yeah and we're trying to predict this
extra bit
so somehow changing slides is always a
bit odd with video
okay so um now
how do we get from the segments to our
initial point cloud representation the
incomplete one
well here this is the output of the
segment that
angelia showed us earlier and we
in this case care about the scissors
which can be seen here
and um basically down here we have
the depth map and we also care about
the exact same pixels or the locations
that we can see up here so we would
essentially just copy
this mask overlay it on there and take
the exact pixel locations
and then do some mathematical jiggery
pokery and turn them
into pointless and as you can see this
if if you just saw this on the internet
you probably wouldn't even know that
scissors
um these are the handles and this part
here is completely sharp bit that you
cut which is completely missing
and here this bit is some noise um
because as you can imagine
the network the segmentation network is
not perfect so the output isn't perfect
so it might actually
output some pixels here as scissors
which actually belong to the table or
some other object
so that's why we see this as noise here
and then comes the really cool part
actually
[Music]
the morphing and sampling network so
this is the network that's responsible
for
completing the point cloud so um this is
actually
uh an adapted picture from the original
paper by luatel
and they published this in aai last year
and we were actually i think one of the
first users of this network
so um right so they took a car
here and got rid of some of the
points as you can see and then they also
put it through an encode
and decoder architecture to get a
complete
representation that you could turn 360
degrees and it would have points
everywhere the special thing here is i'm
just gonna quickly mention that
and i also have an additional slide um
for that
uh for later in the q a if you want to
know more about it
so the encoder here is different from
the one that angely described
it's not a convolutional encoder
um but it's based on point net and point
under
from 2017 and it was the first
architecture that actually enabled us to
deal with point clouds without um yeah
in 3d space and the magic that it does
basically kind of comes from it using
specs of mlps and
each of these mlps is used on all of the
points
so that we actually can handle these
properties of point clouds
right but if you want to know more more
about this just ask me later then it
will
probably get a bit clearer when i show
you the architecture
so uh we put this point cloud through
the encoder
get a general feature vector which is
1024
elements long and then
this is set through the morphing based
decoder and what does this decoder now
do so
this is actually a really cool idea so
they take
a in two-dimensional space they take a
unit square right so this represents
this thing here
and they sample multiple points from
this unit square
and so let's let's see it's this point
so the two coordinates of this points x
and y
are appended to this general feature
vector
and then afterwards they put this whole
vector through multiple
mlps and what this
each of these mlps essentially does is
transforming the
2d plus general feature vector
information
into 3d space and each of them
is um basically transforming it into one
surface element right so and you can see
what the output actually looks like i
hope you can see the
colors but here for instance uh
is one of these elements at the front
where the
car window front window would be so this
would be one surface element
here at the back would be another
surface element here at the front wheel
so yeah that's what it would look like
in the end
and um i've got another picture to
actually show
how this looked like while we were
training because this was quite a big
aha moment
once we once we actually saw this in
action
so here it's at epoch zero so at the
start of training
here's somewhere in the middle and
here's at the end so this is like a
bleach cleanser bottle that we were
trying to predict
and here you can actually see that what
these mlps do at the beginning they're
just randomly initialized
and they just take these sample points
from this
2d square and just project them into 3d
in some orientation and some
translation somewhere in 3d space and
then
as we train these points are actually
stretched out so these status elements
are morphed
that's where the name comes from
into the final 3d
point cloud the complete point cloud and
yeah one additional note maybe you can
you can see it a bit better on the
previous slide so the authors actually
um so this is a
supervised task so they had a ground
truth that they were comparing this to
and and they also tried to make these
surface elements the points in the
surface elements stick
close together so that the point from
the wheel wouldn't end up somewhere
in the back here and um they do this
with an expansion penalty
which basically punishes the points for
going too far away from each other
and why they do this is because um they
wanna
um they want to have the same density of
points
all across the car here in this case
because otherwise you could imagine that
here there may be a big hole while
there's here
quite a lot of points in one place and
yeah
so that's one other thing that they did
in their work
right um and here are actually some of
the results
um so we used four objects from this ycb
video data set
and the first one is the scissors as
you've seen before the bleach cleanser
bottle
a power drill and a banana so all
fairly household objects that a robot
might at some point in the future maybe
interact with
and the pictures with a are always the
incomplete point clouds these are our
completion results so what the
morphing sampling network gave us as an
output
and this is the ground truth and as you
can see for
the scissors and the power drill this
actually looks
quite nice they look very close to the
ground truth maybe the holes they're a
bit
larger but it's actually nice results
and for these two objects we got
overall pretty decent results then for
the bottle
um which is quite a large occlusion here
um the outfit looks a bit wonky so
there's like i don't know um some bumps
here where they where there shouldn't be
any bumps but you know
and the cat's kind of missing and
well the banana looks like it should
have been eaten like two weeks ago
so um i don't know this is one of the
actual good results um so the banana
uh in our case even even though this is
kind of counterintuitive because it
seems to be the easiest object for a
human like it's
such an easy object right and the
scissors seemed so complex and somehow
it didn't
manage to get the banana right most of
the time well
and because we don't want to show you
only the shiny results but also
some outtakes um we're going to show you
what went wrong
so in the first row you can again see
the input point clouds the result and
what they should have been
so for some reason in this case here
from this banana
it made a perfectly looking pair of
scissors
same with the power draw perfectly
shaped scissors i don't know
and here this blob got turned to
into another blob which is um
yeah you can see in high resolution it's
kind of a mix between
scissors and bananas maybe i don't know
there's a banana
and um yeah
what we think happened there is um
maybe that was our hypothesis when we
looked at these results maybe
we actually made the task too easy for
the network
um because what we did was before
we gave the network the point cloud to
complete
we actually brought it into a canonical
position meaning
um if you look at if you look at these
scissors here right they are
um this is the ground truth and it would
be in this position and imagine
my scissors kind of look like this and
they're lying on the ground like that
and we would then transform the scissors
to be in exactly the same
position so that the network wouldn't
have to do this turning around and
translating it in space
um and then we thought okay maybe
the network is just looking at the
object and saying ah
i think i think you're you're a scissors
and then it will just completely
complete it into
the perfectly looking scissor shape that
it learned by heart
so that's what we think might be going
on but the important point here is as
well that
as most of us know probably these things
are black boxes
right so we have no way of we had no way
of knowing at this point why
this was actually taking these decisions
and i just
stumbled upon a paper two weeks ago
um which was actually dealing with
explainability methods so
trying to explain why a network does
something for a point cloud which is the
first
of its kind so to say because usually
i've only seen work done in this
like image classification for instance
so it would actually be really
interesting
to use something like this and look into
why what it's doing there
yeah so uh quickly drink something
before i get into this part
uh this is me and i think some of
my teammates during
the project so there's actually four of
us working on this
and we came across what i will call
the science versus reality gap so
one of our team members alexandre
was actually trying out different
segmentation networks before we
committed to segnet just to see
whether any of them would perform better
or you know
um and she tried out masks mark rcnn and
a few different architectures
and she wrote a meticulous guide of how
to set this up and it included like
install cuda version 8 which is ancient
to work with your gpu install python 3.0
i don't even know five maybe three point
who knows
um set some sim links on your system and
it was just
horrible we tried to actually replicate
this because we thought
what if her i don't know what if her
system goes south
um basically we need to be able to still
train the network
and i think one or two of us tried to
set it up when we just couldn't
so this is one of the things that
really got to us that things were just
not reproducible
and not portable to other systems and um
yeah i think this is uh it's great that
people open source their code
and it's it's a really cool thing to
have with some computer science
and also the scientific repos but it
should also be in the sake of
reproducibility which is really
important in science right
or should be um to have code that's
portable and that
so these can actually reproduce your
results and work on top of them
um and we try to do it better i'm not
sure we succeeded
um but what we did use was we actually
containerized our whole pipeline so
for those of you who haven't heard of
docker or
don't know what a container is it's
basically
imagine you have a virtual machine a
virtual machine is basically
running a whole new os on top of your os
separate
and docker is basically a smaller the
smaller version of that
running or sharing the linux kernel of
your host system
right and you can use um
docker images which are kind of the
recipe
for building docker containers so it's
like a recipe for baking the cake
and you can share these images and
recipes for building these images with
other
people and so they can just replicate
your whole setup very easily
and we try to do this with all of our
components so we have three components
in the system
we have the morphing and sampling
network the segmentation
network and a graphical user interface
and each of these two has all three of
them actually have different
um dependencies even different python
versions different cuda versions and so
on and they all
are packaged neatly into these
containers that run completely separate
from your system but you can still use
um the underlying host systems gpu for
instance during training which is really
cool
yeah and the third one is um because we
wanted to make it end to end right
we actually built a um back then front
end
uh back end based on flask in the front
and ujs so that the user could actually
directly interact upload files from the
ycp video data set
run the completion and then display the
files in the browser
and how does that look like
so the colors are
i love it so the ah please load
ah there we go so this is this is our
gui first of all we have a little drop
down where you can specify
which object you want to complete in
this case the power drill
then in our repository that we
that we uploaded we actually have some
example inputs for each of the objects
so in this case for the power drill we
have three
fires which all need to be uploaded and
this is the color image
i'll see that in a second so this is
this would be the frame
um the second one is the depth image and
then the meter data that we need like
the camera internal parameters and so on
so and then we open this we submit the
files
i've actually cut this just a disclaimer
because it actually takes
a little bit of time um and then
once it's done you can actually see
these point clouds
in action inside the browser so this is
done with a 3js
um so you have an actually interactive
viewport
where you can rotate them movement and
out and on the left hand side
you see the partial point cloud from the
frame and this is the complete
360 degree point cloud with less points
thank you but
yeah okay
please change slides okay right so
nearly at the end
so what should you hopefully take away
from
today first of all um
grasping as we may have seen is not
trivial it's very unconscious for us um
so we do it
every day all day uh since we were very
small children
but nevertheless this task is very
complex for robots
so they have to think about so much
different information
and what we did here uh was actually
just a very small part
right at the beginning of this whole
grafting task so there's a lot of stuff
that comes afterwards like
how you actually plan to move the joints
of the robot and so on
the second point clouds point clouds are
very cool very powerful representations
that you can work with in
3d and they do need um slightly
different
neural network structures than for
instance images
and third um this might be a bit mean
but this also goes
towards myself um science needs to sort
its shitty repos out so that's really
the case i mean it's not that everybody
produces shitty repos that's certainly
not the case but
from what we've seen um during that
project there's really
still room for improvement for instance
writing readme that are
concise and really tell you what you
need to do and so on and also making
it portable and reproducible for the
next person
that actually wants to use your code
because i guarantee you if you do that
you'll get more github stars
so and that's it
uh thank you very much from anjali and
for me
for joining our talk and i've actually
added
a little reference um slide here with
all the papers that we
referenced so for segment morphing and
sampling
also pointnet and this little robot that
you saw before at the beginning
then also the links to the project where
you can actually
hopefully try it out yourself if it
works i really hope so
and um then for those of you who haven't
tried out docker but are kind of hyped
to
to see what it can do for you in deep
learning i actually wrote a
medium article about this which you can
see here
at the bottom so yeah hopefully we can
post the slides as well at some point so
you can
just click on the link thank you
awesome yeah
everybody's clapping with the heart
wow super cool
uh boof thank you for all these
references uh i definitely read this
this million articles
of course one everything
okay time for questions um
you can write in the chat or maybe raise
the hand
i already tried to take some of the
questions in the chat
it's good to give some time
yeah we had some comments on um
how we could improve the results right
so
of course um um steve already mentioned
that the
training data or that there were some
issues in the output probably caused by
the homogeneity of the training
data or the network kind of um
learning some kind of classification
problem where we were like
it would be interesting to actually have
a look into that black box
and um yes someone just mentioned that
more variant
data and augmentation techniques could
be a step we could take to improve that
i like that point for sure
yeah one maybe additional thing that we
also
need to mention is that this ycp video
data set is
video frames right so it's rgbd videos
and so all of the test data as well is
just from
like a handful of videos i think 10 or
so and so
they're all very homogenous so they're
just basically someone
taking this connect camera and going
around the table like this so you just
in each frame you see a slightly
different viewpoint
of the same object and hence
that also has to be taken with a grain
of salt
yeah and also we focused on a proof of
concept um
so this happened in a project for a
master's course so
we had limited time that's why we tried
to focus on four different objects in
the beginning
to just get it right there so um next
step would be
more so we had a question here how much
computing power was needed
um so to give you a sense we um train it
for these
four objects on a
nvidia rtx um yeah this is the semantic
segmentation part which we use the titan
x on
i think we trained roughly a day but we
used way more
um data there so this is on all objects
and then we only trained for the four
objects on the um
morphing sampling one which we did on my
laptop
which is a um like this type gaming
laptop with 6 gb
and that thing was burning and um
yeah that took did i run for two days
straight
or something but i always let it run
overnight for
many hours and um yeah it was a strain
i bought a little um fan to cool it
yeah it was in summer as well so that
was august so it was hot outside and hot
inside but
yeah i'm curious about the
uh washington distance uh that's what
you mean by earth movers distance right
exactly can you tell us how you can tell
us more about that like the
approximation
i'm quite curious on the technical stuff
um yeah so i have to admit that i
um i'm not i'm probably not the person
to ask for the mathematical details
behind it
um so i have well yes the earth moves
distance for everyone who
doesn't know what it is and it's also
called wasserstein distance
um in more amongst uh i guess the maths
community
um it's a measure that we used um
so it's it's a it's a formula that i
didn't put here but um
it's a formula that um you can use to
measure the distance between
distributions or between point clouds
and it's um you can derive it that's why
it's
very nice to use in a network because
you can use it as a loss function
we also use it as an evaluation metric
here
so what it does in words is basically it
measures how much effort does it take
to take one point cloud
and make it equal to another point count
so you basically look at the distances
between the points and look at the
amount of points that you have to
um you have to move but you're trying
not to consider the individual
identities right and so there this is
a very complex um task
to compute and that's why usually you um
you approximate it
and you try to make it paralyzable to um
to um yeah make it run on a gpu
um faster but um for the specifics of
the implementation i
have to point you to the paper or the
repository
um because yeah i'm not i'm not too
familiar
about the mathematical specifics there
sorry about that
yeah there's actually a custom custom
implementation by the authors of the
morphing and sampling
network um yeah i'm not i'm not sure i
didn't i didn't look into it that much
to be honest
i was just happy that it didn't take as
long as the
usually would have taken with other
implementations of emds because it's
expensive would it help if
you know on in addition to the point
clouds uh each point each point had a
color associated to it would it would
that help
we thought about this actually that uh
for this problem it might have
been a good idea to um actually have the
color information for as well because
then the banana or i don't know then the
power drill which is red would have
never been classified as
a banana probably
yeah but we wanted to start as simple as
possible but
that would have been nice to try out as
well well i mean
is it so simpler because you think about
babies when they learn to grasp things
like
they also see right so they learn to
grasp and see they don't just see
surfaces right
so yeah maybe the color learns to helps
to disentangle
certain aspects of uh yeah
so we had another more practical
question
regarding uh where we can find um ai or
deep learning
project
any ideas of i personally uh always
like to look at kaggle so like some top
ranked um
challenges there with notebooks yeah
someone already responded
if you have ideas maybe just type them
in there
with links
any more questions or comments
i guess then thank you all very much for
listening
and uh for your um very good
points and questions um in the end it's
very nice
very nice experience and um yeah hope to
talk to you again